Westeros has seven kingdoms but the Iron
Islands have hundreds every ship and the
waves is a kingdom and every captain and
his leg as a king mainlanders will bow
to a man whose only claim is dropping on
the right cut but the Ironborn spend
their lives at sea we know that if a
captain is weak his men drown if he's
foolish his men drown but if he's strong
his men card their names into the world
with blood steel and sawn any man with a
ship may claim some throne but the rest
of the Ironborn have to give it to him
in the Kingsmen a priest claimed the
first king of the Iron Islands was the
grey king who ruled over the sea itself
in the dawn of days it took a mermaid to
wife in stole fire from the storm gone
and carved the first ship from a demon
tree that fed on human flesh when he
died his hundred sons slaughtered each
other until only 16 remain since none
could overpower the rest in battle they
came together and chose the strongest to
be their king and so began the tradition
of the Kingswood a good story for
children who don't know the grey is wood
men become after their strength has fled
all the brothers do not easily submit
over the centuries the Kings mood has
raised the greatest of the Ironborn
Corot horror whose word was law whenever
men could smell the salt there or hear
the crash of waves he sacked old town
and the feet at the river King taking
three young sons as hostages when their
father's tribute was slate quarry cut
out their hearts with his own hand when
the father marched for vengeance Koretz
smashed his army and gave this river
king to the drowned God how in horror
born to a king who had a flee didn't
sail and swords hidden blood as a nun
rule in worthless youngest son powerin
was sent away to the east to vanish and
so he did but when his father died ahran
returned to the island islands for the
Kingsmen an elder brother objected so an
elder brother fell of a horse and at the
King's with no mana ejected Harvin
launched his father's ships for Westeros
and took ten times the Iron Islands from
its weak Lords who never expected to
face an iron born King as skilled on
land as at sea for Harvin had read with
Eastern pirates and served with East and
sell swords and learned more war and the
after Aegon and his dragons burned our
les King Herod the black and broke
armies the defeated Ironborn chose my
ancestor mekin great John as lord of the
Iron Islands not King four centuries
after the Kingsmen was a joke at the eye
Bowen and get when a Lord Greyjoy died
captains would meet and choose his
eldest son to succeed
of course they argued over it just long
enough to show they weren't now like the
very mainland as they despised one small
we have a true king my own brother Balin
who had the balls to cease the driftwood
crown but let the brains to hold it he
is the first King the Iron Islands have
had in centuries and the fool would be
the last the Kings would once chose him
over me they will not have that choice
next time